[Música]
[Aplausos]
é igual o tema desta palestra é
provocativo
não basta mudar os políticos
eu acho que dá pra maioria de vocês
entenderem mais ou menos significado
disso então que nós vamos falar hoje é
sobre a situação em que o país vive na
qual eu coloquei esta frase que deve ser
conhecida de muita gente ferida pelo
nosso rui barbosa num discurso proferido
no senado brasileiro em 1914
parece me que ele estava falando dos
dias atuais
sobre a atual crise que o país vive
atualmente a quando a operação lava jato
foi iniciada e começou a aparecer a
começaram a aparecer os primeiros
resultados a uma onda de esperança
varreu o país
ou seja aparentemente havia uma coisa
nova que estava produzindo um efeito
realmente grande porque esta figura e
esta foto é icônica dentro desse
movimento e se com todos vocês sabem era
os maiores empresários brasileiros que
estava sendo preso pela polícia federal
e portanto isso nunca tinha acontecido
no país
ou seja esse fato é que criou realmente
muita esperança de que a gente poderia
estar no caminho certo para combater a
corrupção principalmente pra ajudar a
resolver a crise moral que se abateu
neste país desde há muito tempo mas ao
mesmo tempo fica com aquela expectativa
será que apenas a lava jato conseguiria
resolver o problema da corrupção no país
ea resposta veio logo em seguida uma
reportagem do estadão uma entrevista com
esse
é gerar do colombo que foi dos
magistrados que comandaram a operação
mãos limpas na itália
é uma operação que se assemelhava muito
a lava jato e que ela produziu muito
efeito aprendendo políticos e
empresários poderosos do país mas que a
partir do momento em que começou a
descer o nível chegando mais próximo dos
cidadãos comuns
ela começou a perder o efeito população
deixou de dar apoio e um desabafo deste
magistrado é que ele disse que é só a
justiça sozinho seria incapaz de
derrotar a corrupção porque quem acabou
com a operação mãos limpas foi o cidadão
comum seja a gente precisa refletir
muito sobre essa farsa frase justamente
porque se a gente quiser realmente
acabar com a corrupção do país
não basta apenas né
mexer com os políticos porque os
políticos representam apenas a ponta do
iceberg da corrupção na grande a
quantidade de escândalos na sujeira toda
que está debaixo do tapete em nosso país
está na base
você se encontra justamente no cidadão
comum que é aquele que elege os
políticos eles não nasceram lá é um
processo democrático nem eles foram
eleitos pela população
não adianta falar que ele não representa
porque de todos políticos representam
com alguém que faz parte da população e
por isso se a gente pretende fazer
alguma coisa em resposta é aquela
questão que o rui barbosa coloca desde o
princípio a gente pretende fazer alguma
coisa para ajudar a melhorar o país
que tal começar com o cidadão comum que
tal começar com as pessoas tentando
mudar as pessoas pra aí sim produzir uma
mudança mais eficiente na sociedade como
um todo
então essa é a proposta do nosso
trabalho a nós minhas atividades
acadêmicas e profissionais nos vários
projectos que eu tive oportunidade de
participar de coordenar a eu levantei
muita informação importante sobre como
lidar com o cidadão comum porque a minha
área pesquisa de mercado
você e eu trabalho com informações
fazendo pesquisas com a população então
mexer e conversar dialogar com a
população faz parte do nosso trabalho
daí que a em função dessa característica
é é a em 2004 eu tive a oportunidade de
coordenar uma grande pesquisa no estado
de são paulo para avaliar o grau de
felicidade da população do estado
os resultados desse trabalho foram
publicados na edição do globo repórter
da rede globo e que depois foi
transmitida para outros países pela
globo news internacional
é esse trabalho que nós levantamos
informações e quase seis mil famílias
selecionadas de 74 municípios do estado
de são paulo nos deu condições de
entender um pouquinho mais o que é esse
povo pensa sobre felicidade e nós
detectamos levantamos chamado fatores
determinantes na felicidade do povo
paulista que ele atribui a sua
felicidade a fatores tal como a família
a saúde é a própria satisfação com a
vida religiosidade e assim por diante
e que o próprio rebeis materiais o
econômico estava em quinto lugar
mostrando que para nós brasileiros que
por isso pode representar até de certa
forma o brasil
nós tínhamos na e condições de entender
que se eu quero mexer com felicidade com
o bem-estar com qualidade de vida
eu tenho que identificar quais os
fatores naquilo que
população realmente valoriza eu tenho
que entender melhor o cidadão
não basta ter estudos teóricos né que me
diz o que é importante é que não é
importante se o cidadão não entende que
aquilo é realmente importante para ele e
perguntar pra ele
esse trabalho nosso né permitiu entender
isto
em continuidade a esse trabalho sobre
felicidade eu tive a oportunidade de
encontrar o modelo de desenvolvimento de
um país
o botão de um paizinho pequeno entre a
índia ea china país budista que
desenvolveu um modelo chamado fib que
você já deve ter ouvido falar firme
significa felicidade interna bruta onde
recife pe avalia o país mas sob a ótica
dos seus próprios moradores é um
conjunto de indicadores são 33
indicadores que avaliam nove domínios ou
nove dimensões né da vida dos moradores
desse país e que o país se encarrega de
transformar em políticas públicas pra
aumentar a qualidade de vida da
população e então fib que a felicidade
interna bruta não é a felicidade apenas
pessoal de cada um
no fib representa é um modelo de
desenvolvimento em que o pib produto
interno bruto foi substituído pelo filme
felicidade como mais importante pra
população daquele país
então trouxe aqui uma figurinha para
mostrar o botão e se une do tigre é que
é um ícone do botão nem do dia porque
dirceu um dos governantes dos reis
chegou até nós sabe perdão chegou até se
esse local aí nas costas de um tigre
eu gostaria de ter essa coragem é bom
então pensando reunir esses
conhecimentos todos né conhecimento que
a gente tinha trabalhar com a população
sabendo que bom né tentando levantar o
que a população valoriza mas que
mexer com o cidadão comum e detectando
que uma das dos fatores mais importantes
para a população
era a família do futebol então nós vamos
focar a desenvolver um projecto para
focar na família porque o cidadão ele se
encontra ele tem uma família
então esse é o foco do nosso trabalho do
nosso projeto é que nós chamamos de vibe
e que nós vamos tentar implantar aqui na
cidade de são carlos como um
estudo-piloto pra que depois se obtendo
o sucesso que a gente espera ter a gente
possa estender a outras nas localidades
também então nosso foco vai ser família
e aqui está a metodologia que nós vamos
utilizar para conseguir obter resultados
então como nós vamos entrevistar a
família não vale a família não vamos
trabalhar com amostras de famílias e
essas amostras são representativas da
população de são carlos
vamos trabalhar e vamos levantar
mensalmente cerca de 800 família na qual
nós vamos entrevistá las e as
informações vão abastecer esses três
módulos módulo indicadores interesse
público é modo de comportamentos
práticas morais o modo acomoda da
comunicação pública
o modo indicador interesse público vai
levantar os as impressões que a
população tem dos serviços que ela
efetivamente utiliza serviços públicos
que ela utiliza ia cuidar pra gente a
impressão sobre a qualidade de serviço
a diferença desses indicadores para os
indicadores atuais é porque eles nem vão
trabalhar com a impressão do usuário do
serviço e não do ponto de vista do
gestor dos serviços como são os
indicadores atuais a esses indicadores
vão ser divulgados para toda a população
para que ela possa exprimir o seu
descontentamento ou satisfação
alcançando os gestores públicos não é
para que os gestores público ouvindo a
população possa trabalhar
devolvendo para a população aquilo que
ela tá reclamando é e também depois
acompanhar as ações e que vão ser
implantadas a partir desses indicadores
o modo de comportamentos práticos moraes
vai levantar todos os comportamentos
antiéticos violentos que a população o
que a família sofreu mas também vão
levantar os bons comportamentos e vamos
divulgar esses comportamentos de uma
forma ostensiva inteligente criativa
para que toda a população discuta sobre
a pertinência ou não desses atos que da
qual é a própria população acaba
cometendo objetivo é fazer com que cada
um crie um auto sensor que ao cometer
erro nem qualquer delito desde que vai
atingir outras pessoas da própria
sociedade
néné esse infrator reflita e aí pense e
resolva por si só não cometer todos os
atos de violência e finalmente o modo de
comunicação pública ele visa primeiro
conhecer o que a população conhece sobre
direitos e deveres de cidadania conhecer
também vamos lá tentar levantar qual é o
grau de compreensão que a população tem
respeito de leitura e compreensão de
textos para que a gente entendendo isso
possa desenvolver material de divulgação
sobre cidadania direitos e deveres para
levar para essas famílias na linguagem
que elas são capazes de entender é isso
que é o nosso ver assim complementa bené
o conjunto daad de ações que vai fazer
com que a família possa se comunicar com
os gestores públicos respeito nem de
todos os serviços que ela recebe
acompanhando o uso devido do dinheiro
público que possa conversar com os pares
da mesma sociedade do ponto de vista dos
comportamentos impróprios e éticos e
querem que possibilita selecionar
aqueles que devem permanecer daqueles
que a própria sociedade deve suprimir
eliminar né mas essa esse grito ele
deve ser feito de uma forma educada com
o conhecimento que vai ser promovido
pelo módulo da comunicação pública
em suma o projeto eu coloquei esse
símbolo o projeto vai funcionar como
espécie mêda fone de um grande negra foi
o único que vai tentar né fazer com que
a população
grite se manifeste para toda a
comunidade
gestores públicos e população em si para
que ela própria se organize e possa
criar uma sociedade melhor porque s
o que a gente sabe e que está escrito na
nossa constituição no primeiro artigo 1º
artigo 1º parágrafo único desse primeiro
artigo que diz o seguinte a constituição
federal que todo poder emana do povo que
o exerce por meio de seus representantes
eleitos ou diretamente então o que nós
pretendemos chegar com esse projeto é
que a população exerça de fato o seu
papel cidadão previsto na própria
constituição brasileira que ainda nos
rege que tal forma que no final 20 bi
o pib é um modelo que todos conhecem
produto interno bruto que rege o sistema
o capitalismo hoje o fib que é um modelo
um pouco acima porque ele engloba o pib
mas o pib não é o detentor do poder
neste né
nesse governo botão particularmente ou
seja porque a felicidade é mais
importante e nós estamos propondo agora
a nossa o nosso projeto vibe se chama
valor interno bruto
justamente porque não vamos tratar de
valores que a sociedade possui que a
nossa sociedade possui por isso que o
projeto está sendo implantado aqui em
são carlos e eu prometo solicitando para
quem esteja nos ouvindo né pra que faça
uma análise e napoli ou não mas que
venha conversar com a gente porque essa
proposta é a gente acha que tem todas as
condições de chegar realmente nesse
patamar é com o modelo aqui engloba
os demais obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]